hello and welcome to our second dev
diary on marksmen DLC first time around
we took a look at the platform features
and weapons and this time we'd like to
focus in on the new game modes and
missions as we explained in a previous
dev diary the marksmen DLC breaks down
into new premium content and then a
platform update for everyone that owns
ARMA 3 in terms of the PlayBook content
for marksmen on the premium side of
things we have one new showcase as well
as three new firing drills challenges
then the free platform update consists
of the end game multiplayer mode as well
as VR training courses and also the VR
garage plus we have added another
showcase that is boasting a player and
multiplayer showcase so karate Mesa
Terminator propane and ABS I'm Tito Mesa
Mayu Cassidy Thiago technology the
bonito - mama version of a hoe joke as
marksmen we'll be focusing on the new
features that we are adding to the
marksmen DLC platform update the weapon
resting the deployment by pods as well
as letting the player use the new tools
that are available the new weapons the
scopes and the ghillie suits the firing
from vehicle showcase is part of our
free platform update so everyone gets
this scenario we actually introduced
this feature in helicopters DLC but we
felt it was deserving of some more
official content so this new show case
scenario gets plays on a helicopter and
puts them in an interesting scenario
this is sort of a special showcase
because it's both single-player and
multiplayer you can join with four
different friends and completed in
multiplayer or just play on your own as
a normal showcase
last summer we released the ARMA 3
bootcamp updates along with it
we had the virtual reality terrain this
is sort of a special environment where
we created new training topics helping
players get to grips with some of the
core mechanics of ARMA 3 obviously for
marksmen VR training we focused on
weapon handling and introducing these
mechanics to the player properly now
that they are all linked together in the
previous dev diary we focused on the new
mechanics such as the weapon resting and
deployment and we're linking these to
the existing mechanics like recoil
inertia and weapons like firing drills
were designed to be a competitive
shooting sport that allow the player to
train a lot of different things like
tactical movement target prioritization
as well as weapon handling players go
through three different courses compete
against the clock and they have to be
accurate and move intelligently another
part of the free platform update is what
we call the virtual garage this is
something like an extension to the
existing virtual Arsenal and that is
where you can try out configure export
different infantry loadouts try the
weapons that sort of thing so the garage
is an extension of this but for vehicles
so you can put down a vehicle change
different camo pattern that might have
changed the different aspects of its
configuration and then export that to
use in missions dr. bozidar a new jet
abisco shitake whose name was Elam
terrazzo posted a publish so to switch a
tiara dr. Evita Ahmed Services Manager
on Yui another interesting part of the
whole virtual Arsenal and ant garage is
the ability to try out all of the
content in ARMA 3 in one place now that
includes both the premium content and
the platform's
the end game multiplayer mode is another
critical part of the free platform
update it's available to everyone and
this is a new team-based multiplayer
mode the end game basically breaks down
into three phases to begin with players
have to establish a Forward Operating
Base from here they can form groups
change their loadout that sort of thing
in the second phase each side competes
to secure Intel and this Intel
ultimately leads to the location of some
schematics and valuable device the side
that has the most Intel is given the
task to secure the schematics and upload
it to their command meanwhile the other
side is given that house to stop this
from happening modern game super
production i.g racha racha mukashi
subasta are Maya Napa me imam musa me
mattock dispossessed assessment imam
arrazi iraq Jeremy shada planet of
Pomerania dynamics module Sara Kurdistan
as currency which we just we never
explains about my project
in endgame we are also adding a few
experimental gameplay features that
really focus on teamwork and cooperation
there's the revive mechanic as well as
shared objectives and dynamic groups it
nice model yeah more dynamic groups
promote it a totally new Jetta repo
volume unit vector as Cooper Nesta
Freitas about separate numbers company
enables a pyramid which exists Tweety
shared objectives make it possible to
have tasks in the mission assigned to
multiple people and to communicate more
clearly which tasks are available and
who may be already accomplishing it
revived simply is a set of mechanics
that enables players to patch up their
engine teammates it basically avoids the
need to respawn we want to create these
systems so that the community mission
makers can drop down these systems into
their own missions and they get the same
functionality as we have
for me marksmen DLC and a platform
update really complete the infantry
experience it links together all of the
mechanics and makes you as a player
needing to apply proper tactics on a
battlefield to make the best of all of
them no farm service Buddha Babbitt
marksmen DLC Tiger canals Babolat was it
attack mr. Mishima moon askance Raji I
really hope the community and all of our
players can feel that effort and
appreciate what we're trying to do but
at the same time we also own a debt of
gratitude to our players there's been a
whole bunch of great feedback on dev
branch for weeks now thanks for watching
hope you've enjoyed these dev Diaries
and are looking forward to the splendid
new content and features on a favorite
marksmen DLC bye for now